ok welcome to another 50 minute game on
play d4 and yeah this time my Kevin
pretty high rated opponent for 15
minutes got to 178 which is pretty
pretty high the ratings here in this
15-minute pool are considerably lower
then on five minute or blitz or
something ok played bingo play Knight f3
first see what is up to play GC place to
six ok I have some line that I am yeah
that I looked at a while ago with Quincy
to let's go for this
yeah h3 is a usual moving this kind of
setups to prevent something to go to g
form either the snide maneuver on or
Bishop to g4 okay I'm a play tonight t7
most likely he will play on Knight b6 at
some point the question is some what
about this bishop on c4 on do I want to
where do I want to drop it back to don't
want it to be exchanged so maybe play em
play rook here I place Knight b6 I
retreat all the way to f1
I think one one of those ideas would be
to play e6 at some point but position my
pieces in a way that they cannot really
play easily
yes so nicely centralized position it's
not so easy though provide two um er to
play with the clear clear plain here
what what would our next goal see in
this position I think 11 idea that i
like is to try to exchange the g7 bishop
of course which is some at least them
potentially a very good piece start
doing so much right now the g7 bishop
but still it is the most dangerous piece
in the long run so one idea could be
something like Queen to d2 and Bishop h6
try to exchange this other moves that
come to my de a four or a five rooms
like this okay he played 98 not sure
what what the idea behind this it's not
an unusual route sometimes the night
goes to c7 and so on still I wonder what
tortoise what's the concrete point here
one idea maybe completely insane but
could be f5 or you could use this move
to prepare e-cigs both possible well
well there five looks really am
completely completely insane um another
question here is some i played this rook
to d1 maybe it the rooks really belong
to you want a d1 i play rook e1 him in
case he really wants to play a five i
would have played a five yeah okay it's
doing some kind of firm
demonstration here on on the be far
which is doing not much at the moment I
could have also played 'if I've
immediately but maybe this move
certainly doesn't run away i can i can
easily play it next move and now I have
got everything nicely in the middle of
the board
well not sure what is his next move
Queen to be seven maybe order to prepare
night to see seven or maybe really get
something on the B file
11 idea need to be well if I try to
exchange the bishop with them let's say
queen to see one or Queen to d2 then you
would have night a form at some as a
counter play idea ok click green to be
seven really ok
I'm just spotting one a very good idea
Bishop takes c3 he could have played
this actually last move with the idea if
I take with the porn it's got bishop age
for winning an exchange if I take with
the keenest got nine a form wouldn't be
too funny funny really he could have he
could have won some material with this
weird move amazing okay um I think I
apply b3 now take this possibility out
of the position and prepare to to get a
night to c4 yes ok we can of course some
go here and maybe win this porn with
something takes on some c3 but well if
he wants to he can give me this this
Bishop don't mind is too much let's say
not to be for Queen here and he takes
now it takes a two we can do that which
is just blend as a piece
oh well this was very generous yeah well
a shame it was an interesting
interesting position certainly I have
take back disabled TM I would have
allowed it actually to get a decent
decent game let's try to maybe I can
change this year somehow
yantis disabled because I fan take makes
somewhat strange and unusual blitz games
but it's somewhat awful in such a game
you already spent 10 minutes and 2 10
minutes of coventry and so on I am I now
sent the tape back request
no our new reaction yet not much not
much more that I can do then send the
request myself
you
yeah no reaction no not much more that I
can do okay he just plays on with the
piece down instead of accepting the
request yeah okay then let's finish this
game actually I could have played a
three and when just just another piece
stupid am I was just I just wanted to
play I played a for just two to save
this pawn yet I could have played a
three and a sense of peace s no square
okay about it some it's no use anyway
completely it's also weird you could
have just accepted them the take-back
request yeah I'll resign the game
whatever
yeah okay it's just a piece up end and
I'll also get some nice attack here of
course because this piece is just dead
on before so in effect it's more than
one piece 9406 coming up
Chuck yeah I remove Winston
ok
yeah try to play for me Tia the direct
threat now we are k the sum prevents a
direct mate
okay let's check now if I got the direct
media queer 92 h5 threads on g7 ok you
can play Quincy three okay okay let's
say it takes Queen FG five check King 2
h8 f6 threatens some made on g7 you can
only cover with Luke g8 and then we'll
create and it's over this should be made
yeah but yes hi he's got Queenie one so
at the final trick here so I need to I
need to prepare this well besides the
fact that every everything else also
went to just mix trapeze and so on but I
really try to do a medium ok you get
some mega ok I can't always take this
year so what he would have the check
here possibly
Mia but it's just one check I'm covering
this
the age what I'm doing right now it's
not really advisable trying to punish
his that is playing on by trying to
really win by made but i think it's just
working so need to be honest you really
hate it when people playin on completely
lost position and simply waste time
completely pointless okay even this is
made
black resides Young was some here
somewhat of a shame that he blundered
this piece um did offer take back not
much more that I can do um pretty weird
i'm not sure what how how how did this
happen not sure what what did you
overlook there sometimes those kind of
blunders are due to UM due to the smart
move set up so you just accidentally
click on a piece and it just got one
move and then smart move does this move
it did happen to me quite a lot so no
kin no idea maybe it was just an
oversight yeah okay this is just extra
piece and joining whatever you like but
I could have played a three year this
was stupid just wins the night it has no
place to go but ok it's an extra piece
and completely winning some yeah well
thanks for watching anyway and yeah I'll
keep uploading new videos preferably in
the 15 minute format it's just more yeah
it's less stressful for me to do them so
um I do this 50 I do 45 minute
occasionally yeah but right now 15 this
suits me fine yeah thanks for watching
and leave comments or questions and here
on the comment section of the videos I
got your quite a lot of comments on the
recent videos but I didn't really manage
yet to go through them and post answers
and so on it sir it's lots lots of stuff
to write some and hopefully I get to
this soon yeah thanks and see you see
you soon for new videos